こんにちはゆう smap パーズ agu 代表の平野区にあるです
今回はこのような素晴らしい舞台を用意していただき光栄に思っています
新型コロナウイルスの影響によってをのないんでの開催となってしまいましたができる
限り皆さんの心に届くように私たちの活動を伝えていけたらなと思います
まず私たちいうスマパー jagu は青山学院大学地球社会共生学部付橋金型室内で
結成されたチームです
各年11月に私と2年生2人の3名でスタートしましたが今ではインフレて
7名で活動を行っています
私たちの活動目的はイングという新たな社外社会貢献の形を皆さんに伝えていくこと
です
今回は私たちの活動内容も含めた
紹介を行っていきます
まず皆さんは静と言われて何を思い浮かべるでしょうか
生活には必ず欠かせないものですよね
友達と味合わせをするとき
家族でドライブに出かけるとき
新しい土地に行く時には必ず静が必要になります
色地雷に日本中を歩き回って作られたのが日本史ずです
作ったのは位の忠敬であれは17年の歳月をかけて日本中をくまなく歩き回りし図を
完成させました
しかし現在ではパソコンや衛星などの素晴らしい技術があります
私たちブースまっパース agu は日本全国の皆さんが
伊能忠敬になれるような8品熊素晴らしさを伝えていけたらなと思います
そしてこの発表が終わった頃には皆さんが
マッピングをしてみたいと思えるような発表にしたいと思います
さて私がなぜこの活動を始めたかというとチーズを作るということが壮大な人が助けに
なっているということに気づいたからです
私は世界中で苦しむ難民の問題に興味があり
この地球社会共生学部に入学しました
将来は世界中の難民を自ら足を運んで助けたいと思っていました
しかし転機が訪れたのが古橋先生の授業を受けたときのことです
パソコン一つで国際貢献ができることを知ったときの感動は今でも忘れることができ
ません
その時のオンラインマッピングの衝撃が忘れられる
私はこのプロジェクト立ち上げました
をが7人のメンバーもマッピングの将来性に希望感じて集まってくれました
そしてそれから炎のゲーマーピング活動を行ってきました
そして私たちの活動が波に乗り始めたきっかけとなったのが
真宝しまやアイデンティティなどの楽曲で有名な人気ロックバンドサカナクションの
ボーカルを務める山口一郎さんとのインストアライヴでのコラボでした
今回は著作権の関係で実際の映像を見せすることはできませんが
サカナクションファン約4千人が見守る中での配信は
私にとって夢のような20分間でした
ツイッターでは私の配信内容のまとめページができるなど反響も大きく多くの方々に
私たちの活動内容に興味を持っていただくことができました
この形で地図を作るという
ぱ魚を知っていただけただけでなく私たちのモチベーションもあがり
活動に意欲を持つことができるようになりました
ここまで mapping mapping と言ってきましたが大学で私たちは地位
学などを専攻しているわけではありません
人皆さん思うでしょう大学霊地学を専攻していない私たちがチーズを作ることは簡単な
のかどう
本当に簡単ですパソコン1台があれば誰でもチーズを作ることができます
チーズを作る時
使うツールが2つありますひとつ目がオープンストリートマップ
通称 aos m です
これは世界中のボランティアによって作られる地図で大手 it 企業などがつくる汁
とは異なり小宵様が無料となっています
このチーフが使われているのが気モンゴウや
ingress などの位置情報源
そして登山用時計のデジタル地図としても使われています
次に使うツール2つ目がホット+キングマネージャーです
これは世界中の災害や
紛争などによって地図作成が必要となっている地域を osm オープンストリート
マップを使って効率よく
地図作成するためのツールです
最近では九州北部豪雨や途上国における新型コロナウイルス集団健康診断などに
を行うために
どこに建物や道があるのかを現場で活動する人々がいち早く知るために使われています
ではここでチーズを作る過程を紹介します
まず最初に
フォトパスキングマネージャーを起動させます初心者の方は
建物を入力す建物だけを入力するタスクを選んでください
タスクを開始すると同時に
まず建物を見つけたらエリアボタンを押して建物のカードの部分をクリックします
そこから順番に
建物
スミオ
すべて真澄をクリックしていき最後に直角補正をかければ建物の入力が完了します
これをこの赤い枠の中に存在する全ての建物に行えます
国や地域によって1バスクで何千個も
入力するようなタスクもありますがあまりにも建物が多い場合はパス区を分割すること
ができます
建物の入力がすべて終わったら最後に保存ボタンを押します
これをした時点でオープンストリートマップのチーズは変更されて新たな建物がある
状態の地図となります
そしてホットパスキングマネージャーのコメント欄にどれくらい建物を入力したか問題
点はあったか
コメントすることによって再びマッピングする人も参考になります
どうでしょうかこれだけの作業で皆さんは世界で苦しむ人々を救うことができます
新型コロナウイルスによる自粛期間が続いている今ではおウチのパソコンで
ボランティア活動という現代の方
奉仕活動における最適解水っていいと私たちは考えています
最初にご紹介したように私たちの活動目的はチーズを作ることの簡単さや意味を
一般の方々に伝えていくことです
現在日本ではこれらのマッピング活動がまだまだ普及していません
その理由の一つとして日本語版ホームページが存在していないことにあると私たちは
考えています
地図を作るというだけでとかかりにくいのにその資料が英語だけだとさらに嫌気がさし
てしまいますよね
先ほど紹介したオープンストリートマップとフォトパスキングマネージャーはすでに
日本語版サイトがあります
私たちは自粛期間にマップスワイプという
マッピングアプリの日本語版サイトを作りました
まあ下スワイプというのはホットパスキングマネージャーの前段階で使用するアプリ
です
このアプリでは建物の入力ではなく建物が存在するのかどうかを写真を見てイエスか
ノー人スワイプするアプリです
このアプリによってホッとパッキングマネージャーにおいて
建物のない地域を選択してしまうロスがなくなるようになりました
またスマホアプリということで多くの方々に気軽に使っ使っていただけると思います
は物ワイプの日本語版ホームページの協力団体の欄には私たちいう smap パーツ
エイジング言うと古橋研究室のロゴも奇怪されています
ここまでチーズの作り方や活動のきっかけを話してきました
今後は私たちインスタグラムなどを活用して
マッピングの方法をみなさんに伝えていくこと大そして今までの日本語あんぺー
小さく性を引き続きエコなっていきたいと思っていますファティ青山学院大学付属校に
おけるパティ
利用なども考えています
新型コロナウイルスの影響でどこまで実現可能かはわかりませんが
実際に高校生などに教えていくことで
マッピング人口を増やしていくことができると私たちは考えています
今回のてレックスの底周りビートでした
私は地図というのは生活に欠かせないものだと思っています
今まで行ったこともない土地に箸を運ぶのにも必ず地図は必要になります
言うなれば実は私たちの人生を豊かにする大切なツールなのです
そんなチューブはもう技術者だけが作れる時代ではありません
皆さん自身で自分の生活を豊かにするチーズを
地図を作れる時代になったのです
そして自分の人生だけでなく世界中で苦しむ人々の生活を豊かにすることも
このマッピングでは可能です
コロナはロスジェネんセラーになると言われていますが私はこのマッピングという新た
なボランティアの形を右がで行っていけば今世界はより良い世の中になると確信してい
ますさあ皆さんで
この世界をより良くする地図を作っていきましょう
ニュースが part agu 代表脳死額に貼るでした